this is the first time that Will Smith
has not some the theme song for men in
black movie they got pitbull men in
black 3 is the first movie that Will
Smith has done since seven pounds in
December of 2008 from the very beginning
I thought men in black fit was an odd
sequel choice you know it's ten years
since meta black to minor black 2 was
not good I loved the first one I heard a
lot of things people were saying about
production issues script problems acting
issues just all kinds of different
issues that went on with the shoot I saw
a lot of underwhelming trailers that
weren't really that funny nevertheless I
went into this movie optimistic because
I try to be optimistic about movies
without letting a whole bunch of stuff
cloud my judgment basically what happens
in this movie is something happens where
Tom Lee Jones's character Agent K is
suddenly just forgotten in the mix he's
just gone somehow Will Smith agent J
goes back to 1969 meets a young K played
by Josh Brolin there's this villainous
guy play by Jemaine Clement there his
name is Boris the animal
let me start with the positives Josh
Brolin he is excellent in this movie
he's actually part of my favorite part
of this movie he does a spot-on Tommy
Lee Jones impression but it's not just
his impression that was really good he
had very good chemistry I thought with
Will Smith I thought they played off
each other really well Rick Baker's
makeup is astoundingly good the
prosthetics in this movie the
animatronics terrific I loved how much
of this was animatronic and not CGI that
was a really good plus for me it's fun
to see Will Smith back I really like
Will Smith I'd like to grew up with him
the 90s Fresh Prince of bel-air all the
way through Independence Day and that
you know men in black and that huge
explosion he had of greatness I've
always liked Will Smith I think he's a
very good actor it's fun to see him back
here and as I saw those trailers and as
they underwhelmed me and I was thinking
you know what they're saving all the
good jokes for the movie they're saving
all the big action shots for the movie
there's going to be a lot more it really
wasn't trust me this is a really
disappointing movie and I'm sorry to say
it I'm usually not a big fan of
disappointing you guys but this movie
just did not have much going for it the
comedy is weak a lot of the jokes fall
flat the action is virtually tensionless
there's just there's nothing remarkable
about this movie really honestly just
the makeup the special effects are very
good it's a nice looking movie
it's just not very good I rarely laughed
in this movie there were a few jokes
that worked a few gags that were funny
when I think about this movie nothing
really sticks out for me I just I feel
like in a couple days this movie is just
gonna go fluke and I'll be on to the
next thing Jemaine Clement as a villain
when the film opened I was like yeah
this is gonna be a cool character you
know they set him up really nicely but
then he just doesn't really do anything
for the whole movie he just wanders
around
grunting and making faces and there's
just nothing special about his villain
and all the whole time-travel plot was
kind of interesting it was cool to see
Josh Brolin as Tommy Lee Jones he's
probably the best part of this whole
movie as I said earlier I really like
the dynamic between him and most Smith
it's just that everything felt so forced
it all just felt like a giant cash grab
it felt like there was no reason to make
men in black 3 it's like I just went to
Tom Lee Jones and was like hey man you
gotta be in this movie at some point
well just make it like a time-travel
plot we're going to be in there for like
the first scene a last scene just have
some whole thing in the middle where I
don't wanna have to be there you know
just do that like Tommy Lee Jones the
actor barely in the movie even Will
Smith just seemed like I don't really
want to be here I don't want this to be
my comeback vehicle what am i doing it
just everything felt so forced 3d I
thought was really bad it hurt my eyes
it stung my eyes it made my eye on water
and I see a lot of 3d movies and I
believe this was post converted nothing
seemed to stand out the depth of field
was all mixed up there were shots where
Will Smith was walking and I could
actually see where the black hair and
the white background of the sky was like
slightly overlapping one of my biggest
problems in this movie though is this
side character this this guy who can
foresee the future and he starts to list
everything that's about to happen
immediately before it happens
this guy was Jar Jar Binks level
annoying for me this guy just really got
on my nerves man and something about
that character did not work for me
Wow I just wanted him to get off the
screen but he kept coming back in step
coming back and they kept dragging him
back into the the scenes and I was like
no no no more of this man please like I
said it's fun to see Will Smith back
it's fun to see another man in black
movie and hope that it's gonna be good
and there are some fun moments in this
movie there are some fun moments there
are a few jokes where I laugh but the
whole thing
so bland and dull I wanted to tell you
this movie was good I wanted to tell you
that it was good I'm Arjun mmm why don't
you be better this not very good man in
black 3 one thing about this movie I
really did like though without spoiling
anything I really like the way this film
concluded I'm not talking about like the
last scene I'm talking about like the
way some things were resolved it was
unpredictable and I did surprise I mean
I was a little bit touching as well it
was like out of nowhere was like
suddenly the screenwriter just was like
I got a great idea I'm gonna write it
down should I do that for the rest of
the movie no oh it's fine I'm sorry to
say men in black 3 was very
disappointing I'm going to give men in
black 3 a c-minus it is however a little
bit better than the second one I think
it has that going for it but I mean
that's not really saying much at all so
I'd like to know what is a big movie you
guys were looking forward to in the past
where it just disappointed you on every
level and you're like oh that was just
not what I needed right now and as
always guys if you like this review you
can subscribe to my channel and get
stuck my god